first things first when you're chopping
onions you want to secure your board and
make sure that it's not wobbly so the
easiest way to do that is to grab some
paper towels get them a little bit damp
and put them under your board when
people first start cooking they tend to
want to use a smaller knife chest knives
tend to have a little bit better grip
and when you're cutting you have just a
tiny bit more control and is actually a
lot safer so our first method is going
to be dicing and the first thing that
we're going to do is cut off the tip
and as with any cutting technique that
we're ever doing we want to get the flat
side down so that it's not rolling
around it's nice and flat and secure so
we will just turn this guy upside down
and we're going to cut this guy right in
the middle and then from here we can
very easily peel off this papery bit and
also i like to take off the first layer
of onion as well it's a little bit
leathery and a little bit dry and it
won't really break down we're cooking so
we don't want this at all
so we'll put one of these off to the
side and make sure you've got plenty of
room to work with on a lot of shows or
tutorials you might see that you need to
make a lot of these horizontal cuts in
there once you get to the top it can get
a little bit dangerous so what you want
to do is just very carefully place your
hand on top of the onion so it's flat
and then take your shop's knife and do
one or two horizontal cuts going all the
way through the onion but not quite
hitting the root
and then you're going to turn the onion
towards you and make cuts like this all
the way across the onion and whenever
i'm cutting i'm going to use my hand
kind of like a claw to make sure that
i'm not cutting off my fingers so you
can kind of use these knuckles right
here
as a guide and kind of always have them
upright like this so that the knuckles
are touching the side of the knife and
you're going to keep your fingertips
curled in a little bit and that's going
to prevent you from cutting your finger
don't worry about these straggly bits
that fall off we can get those later
and then we're going to turn the onion
over again and then we'll do those nice
even
rolling slices
and still using your claw hand you're
going to kind of push the onion together
again with your pinky and your thumb
just to keep the onion more intact when
you're slicing and once you get to this
point where you can't really hold the
onion anymore because you've cut so much
of it just flip it over
and you can finish your cuts
and get the most out of your onion and
then that's all the waste you have
so when you're going to get your onions
off the board don't scrape your
knife with the cut side on your board
because that will dull it very very
quickly so what we're actually going to
do is kind of flip this guy around and
use the bottom to be scraping and only
get enough that's comfortable don't try
and get it all at once a couple extra
chips won't kill you and that's dicing
an onion
so next i'm going to show you how to
slice an onion two different ways and
we're going to do the same thing we did
last time we're going to cut off the tip
and again we're going to put it flat
side down
use our claw hand
cut straight down put one off to the
side tear off the papery layer also a
little trick is to use the heel of your
knife to get under those layers if you
don't want to get it under your nails so
there's two different ways to slice an
onion you can go this way or this way
most people are comfortable doing it
this way but when you slice
this way and start to cook they actually
start to break down and turn kind of
into mush these are great for any dish
with raw onions like a salad and then
for anything else i'll show you the
other kind of way to do it so again
we're going to go the flat side down but
we're actually going to turn it towards
you also since you're going to be
cutting it this way and you don't really
have to hold on to the root you can just
go ahead and cut this off and then same
thing using that claw hand and these are
for any dishes where you're going to
need cooked onion and the easiest way to
remember that is just to look at the
lines on the onion and cut with those
lines if you're cutting with those lines
the onion's going to stay more intact
and it'll stay together more when you're
cooking once it starts to get hard to
hold on to you can just turn it down
that way and start again and then once
you get to the edge just take your time
and voila
next we're going to do onion rings so
for the onion rings we're going to start
this one a little bit differently we're
going to cut the top off the onion and
we're actually not going to peel this
one and we're going to leave this on so
that we have something to hold on to
what i am going to do is cut a little
bit off one of the sides kind of where
those outer layers are we're not going
to use those outer layers anyway and it
just gives us a flat surface to work on
so this way when i'm trying to make
rings it's not rolling all over the
place and with these because it is a
smaller edge just take your time i'm
always going to have my claw ready to go
we can do nice
thin rings for something like a burger
and we can do a nice
thicker slice for something like onion
rings and then at this point all we
really have to do is just kind of press
it in whichever way is easier
and make them into those individual
layers
and again if there's any of the outer
bit that is a little bit rubbery and
thick just get rid of that all together
and you're left with these beautiful
nice rings
these are great for making a variety of
tasty videos guacamole onion rings
spinach and onion dip onion rings if you
can stuff it and freeze it we'll fry it